renee tell us what the show is about
girls five eva
is about a one hit wonderful girl group
oh do you like that i just will just
render well
from you know from the 90s 90s and it's
really beautifully done because you see
them at their
you know the height of their fame and
excitement about being young
and being famous and living all their
dreams and being together and then you
smash cut
to 20 years later and you see where they
are in their lives as a result of some
choices
they've made specifically my character
and uh yeah
and the beauty is they uh you know life
throws them a curveball
and they get a second chance i love that
via a rapper's
sampling of their song and they they
they actually you know you'll you will
you'll go on the journey with them
having the audacity to think that they
can do pop music again
together i love it paula we're going to
show a clip will you please
set it up as you say in the talk show
world yes in this
clip girls 5 eva is current day and they
are trying to get their act together
literally and
they are doing an old song they used to
do called the splingy
which is a very complicated dance
and there is a full version actually
available because we have an album
uh that you can download but it is a
very complicated dance there's a lot of
instructions in it and if you don't pay
attention
things go go wrong so this is even if
you do pictures
yeah this is us trying to uh to
pop our pop our booties to the splingy
okay let's take a look
[Music]
obviously this is not the venue to debut
the splingy it's meant to be performed
on top of a building with adequate
netting
[Laughter]
um okay so busy um there is
a story about you being um and you
wanted to work the choreography and you
took it a step
further oh yeah well listen
you know as an actor an actor prepares i
learned on white chicks
and so uh meredith scardino who is
incredible and created the show
uh called me texted me and said
hey we're working on this thing for an
upcoming episode
and um do you by any chance pole dance
and i said i don't yet but i'm going to
and so then i found my own
pole instructor yumi uh
yamiko harris she's incredible and she's
a competitive pole
dancer and uh now i'm i'm really
and she killed it
that is it's a jew so hard look at that
it's so hard that's amazing but she gets
so good
yeah it gets so good i do get good do
you know how hard that is to do you
don't even understand well i can't even
hold on a
poll in the subway
i like got my legs wrapped around it and
i'm gonna fall and she's like swinging
but the other thing is too it's because
it's a tina fey show you know like the
jokes are so
fast it's like i did all of this
training and
the scene is legitimately 15 seconds
so i mean i feel good about it but it
also was like
you know sarah i know that your
character had a little bit of a past
um and uh let's take a look because we
have a clip to
show it oh hey do you think it's too
cold for these
if i wear thick beyonce tights under him
did jeter buy you those
no drew barrimore and tom green sent
them because they wanted
it's a different time
i'm happy to say tom and i are now like
so
close again and it's so nice because we
didn't speak to each other for like 18
almost 20 years wow how did that line
come about
how like what was the randomness because
it's not like
you know either of us i don't i don't
know it doesn't seem like we're topical
it's the brilliant mind of meredith
gardeno and
the the team of writers that she and
and tina and jeff and everybody was very
collaborative but it's
brilliant meredith she's just has this
incredible way of picking things that
are
what i love is that it's always a unique
choice and it's immediate it
it all of a sudden paints a very
visceral picture of a place
time energy she's just like ungodly
funny it's so
good it's so great to just be handed
hilarious scripts and you don't
have to do anything yeah to them and
then you get handed
fantastic music from jeff richmond and
and sarah bareilles and you're just like
oh i i don't
have to do anything except just learn it
and
i had i had some googling to do i have
to say
they're so brilliant sometimes i'd have
to google what in the world the
reference was
but but it was so brilliantly done
because we flashed back to the 90s oh
yeah
and uh and you know and they and they
had to find a reference that was
felt so forever in the 90s that yes not
here anymore and that that's kind of
where a lot of that was dreamt
up well the good news is the 90s are
back like
a decade it was the 80s and we're just
gonna keep going full circle
over and over and if there's one
constant north star
from the past present and in the future
it's girlfriends
yes i agree
great i don't love this show i can't
thank you
sarah varelas paula powell renee elise
goldsberry and busy phillips all
episodes of girls
five emma again i can't stop i'm sorry
are streaming now on peacock get it
while it's hot
laugh love sing dance enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]